نعم حتى اللحظه المعلومات المتوفره تشير
الى ان مسيره اسرائيليه استهدفت سياره في
بلده كفره القريبه من بلده ياطر وهي تبعد
على الحدود نحو 10 كيلومترات تقريبا هذه
المنطقه تستهدف لاول مره بالمسيرات
الاسرائيليه حتى الان المعلومات وفقا
لمصادر في فرق الاسعاف بان هناك اصابات
داخل هذه السياره التي لم يتضح بعد من
بداخلها الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه
كانت شنت هذا اليوم اربع غارات
على مركبه بلده مركبه ومحيطها وهي المنطقه
القريبه والمحاذي تحديدا
لمستوطنين شمونه الطائرات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه تق قامت بالقاء صواريخها
باتجاه هذه المنطقه حتى الان لم يفد عن
اصابات في صفوف المواطنين او في صفوف
مقاتلي حزب الله ال هذه المعلومات التي
توفرت من هذه الغارات التي ايضا اصابت
بشظايا اضرارا في منازل المواطنين في تلك
البلده هذه المنطقه تواصل القوات
الاسرائيليه قصفها باستمرار خلال ووصلتها
خلال الايام الماضيه ايضا خلال الليله
الماضيه شهدنا اطلاق قذائف مدفعيه ودبابات
من منطقه ل المطلي باتجاه العديسي
المحاذيه لمركبه وايضا باتجاه باب حوله
التي قصفت الليله الماضيه بغاره جويه
وايضا بقصف
مدفعي هذا اليوم شهد كذلك قصفا مدفعيا
اسرائيليا على سهل الخيام وتحديدا المنطقه
بين الخيام
ومنطقه برج الملوك
وهي المقابله
لمستوطنين الراس بنت جبيل يرون واستهدفت
المدفعيه الاسرائيليه تلك المنطقه بعدد من
القذا ئف بالاضافه الى عي الشعب والحين
المسيرات الاسرائيليه لازالت تحلق في
اجواء المنطقه وكذلك الطيران الحربي فيما
يبدو ان هناك تاهب اسرائيلي جوي في في
منطقه جنوب لبنان وهو ما تقوم به القوات
الاسرائيليه باستمرار منذ عده ايام في
مناطق مختلفه وتستمر المقاتلات
الاسرائيليه بطلعات الجويه المختلفه فوق
المناطق اللبنانيه في ليس في الجنوب فحسب
وانما في المناطق القريبه كذلك ن نشير
ايضا الى ان حزب الله شن قبل قليل هجوما
بالصواريخ على موقع برانيت وما هو ما
اعلنه قبل دقائق من الان ووجه صواريخه
باتجاه هذا الموقع وقال في بيان نشره
الاعلام الحربي بانه حقق اصابات في صفوف
الجيش الاسي